parler d'un sport national à présent
surtout en période d'inflation la
passion des tours enjaux pour leur
grande braderie encore plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de visiteurs ainsi
que 600 exposants pour cette 28e édition
hier et comme toujours les bonnes
emplettes étaient à la fête et la
Turquie
pas de doute nous sommes bien à la
grande braderie de Tours l'événement
devenu institution dans la région
rassemble chaque année de nombreux
curieux venus profiter des stands et du
beau temps c'est l'occasion de se
divertir un petit peu par une belle
journée ensoleillée puis de faire
quelques achats de sortir en famille
puis voilà on en profiter tous ensemble
et histoire de faire des bonnes affaires
éventuellement une petite balade du
dimanche un dimanche de sortie en
famille avant la rentrée mais aussi
l'occasion de faire quelques économies
deux t-shirts pour 15 euros moins 70%
sur les sacs et 5 euros la robe les
promotions n'échappent pas autour en Jau
en ces temps d'inflation les vêtements
coûtent très cher en ce moment moi qui
suis très vintage ces choses comme ça
c'est plateformes c'est vrai que là la
braderie c'est le moment aussi de
regarder les bonnes affaires oui se
faire plaisir à pas trop cher parce que
c'est vrai que maintenant ça devient
horrible pour s'habiller boulevard
Béranger du côté de l'espace troc les
200 particuliers exposants en profitent
pour faire du tri et quelques bénéfices
moi je trouve que c'est le bon moyen de
d'utiliser les choses leur donner une
deuxième vie ou troisième vie parce que
moi je suis très contente j'ai des
jeunes filles qui descendent de Paris et
qui achètent mes vêtements parce que
elle trouve que c'est moins cher qu'à
Paris je leur fais des petits prix parce
que ça m'amuse beaucoup ça améliore la
retraite quand même un peu
chacun y trouve donc son compte 78e
édition de la braderie aura rassemblé
plus de 600 exposants dans tout le
centre ville de Tours